gérard collomb le sénateur maire
socialiste de lyon est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous vous conservez on peut
le dire depuis l'alternance votre
liberté de ton
tous ne vous plaît pas dans les
priorités du moment gérard collomb vous
nous le dire et d'ailleurs dès le début
de cette émission réalisée pour la
première fois cette semaine en
partenariat avec dailymotion acteurs
majeurs du net évidemment qui permet
d'ailleurs aux téléspectateurs de vous
interpeller et de réagir à cette
émission avec également toujours comme
partenaire l' agence france-presse
représenter ce soir par suzette bloch
qui vous interrogera elle sur votre
défense obstinée du cumul des mandats et
oui en opposition avec françois hollande
et puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous rejoindra en fin d'émission pour
ouvrir certains dossiers lyonnais
oui qui vous met d'ailleurs aussi
parfois en opposition avec la politique
gouvernementale je pense à la réforme
des rythmes scolaires on ne sait
toujours pas si vous allez appliquer
cette réforme dès la rentrée de
septembre on sait qu'en ce moment vous
devez vous socialiste vous porter au
secours de vincent peillon qui est bien
empêtré dans cette réforme des quatre
jours et demi d'école
un mot d'abord gérard collomb sur
l'intervention au mali décidé par le
général
hollande est ce qu'il s'agit pour vous
d'un tournant ou d'une parenthèse du
quinquennat d'abord je voudrais dire que
je pense que c'est une bonne décision
on pouvait pas laisser se constituer
dans cette région du monde
un foyer qui aurait été un foyer où le
terrorisme aurait pu avoir ces bases et
frappé au sein même de la france donc je
crois que françois hollande a eu raison
d'intervenir et donc c'est une bonne
décision alors ce que est ce que c'est
un tournant ce bien sûr que ça change
son image par exemple c'était la crise
en route sans doute un peu ça change son
image c'est une bonne décision
comment était-il avant comment le
voyez-vous maintenant je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse aborder à les problèmes
comme cela mais c'est clair que il a
pris ses responsabilités que la france
est intervenue en plus de manière
extrêmement efficace qu'aujourd'hui les
problèmes de court terme sont réglés ce
de moyen terme évidemment reste encore
totalement ouvert mais c'était une
décision courageuse et de la prise
courageusement voilà il nous a pas
surpris non je trouve que c'est bien
est ce que vous attendez aussi d'abord
surtout le général hollande contre le
chômage ou évidemment je crois que c'est
la question principale des français
aujourd'hui les problèmes d'emploi les
problèmes de désindustrialisation sont
évidemment au coeur de l'actualité je
lisais encore sur les journaux
d'aujourd'hui
depuis 2009 un millier d'entreprises
industrielles qui ont fermé évidemment
que c'est un problème extraordinaire et
que cela affaiblit notre pays et créer
beaucoup de malheur pour un certain
nombre d'habitats lors les plans sociaux
sont bien sûr très présent dans
l'actualité politique gérard collomb
mais en ce moment il ya un débat qui
domine c'est le mariage du est ce que
vous estimez qu'il est temps de passer à
autre chose
je crois que évidemment c'est pas la
question que se posent celles et ceux
qui sont effectivement victime les
problèmes du chômage aujourd'hui et donc
il ne faudrait pas que le ps demain soit
perçue uniquement comme le parti qui
s'occupe des problèmes sociétaux
même s'ils sont importants mais celui
qui résout les problèmes auxquels notre
pays est confronté et le défilé
essentiellement économiques et sociales
et à mon avis c'est là dessus que le
gouvernement doit pouvoir concentrer ses
efforts donc il ne tombe pas fait autre
chose
ah il faut qu'on examine ce texte de loi
puis après on essaye de revenir sur les
problèmes économiques et sociaux qui
d'ailleurs ne nous attendent pas parce
que comme vous l'avez signalé la crise
c'est tous les jours peut être plus
c'est immédiatement et donc ses
problèmes son pendant sur le mariage gay
pour être clair est-ce que vous êtes
100% pour vous j'ai beaucoup réfléchi
voyez au départ j'étais de ceux qui
pensaient que ce que l'on avait fait
avec le pacs était suffisant à certain
nombre d'amis m'ont convaincu pour le
mariage mais par contre sur la pma
la gestation pour autrui je pense qu'il
ya des bornes qu'il faut remarquer que
le situez vous personnellement lors donc
vous êtes pour le mariage gay est quoi
finale gp on s'arrête là pour moi
on s'arrête là définitivement oui je
dois avant et je crois que ça
permettrait justement de désamorcer un
certain nombre de critiques de gens qui
disent mais ce n'est qu'un premier pas
demain on ira plus loin par exemple la
critique fait sylviane agacinski sur la
gestation pour autrui en disant
attention ne pas faire en sorte que
demain il ya un nouvel esclavage féminin
qui naissent au sein de notre pays
c'est une critique quand même qu'il faut
entendre et qui à mon avis beaucoup de
poids et vous entendez aussi les
critiques sur la procréation
médicalement assistée qui ne doit pas
être ouverte aux couples de lesbiennes
donc si je vous entends bien vous êtes
sur cette ligne là fait que la chance
selon sur le mariage point très bien et
demain vous pourriez en procédés
d'ailleurs cérémonie dans votre mairie
de lyon vous le ferez vous même le maire
de lyon ne marie pas ça se passe dans
les arrondissements devraient priver de
ça les rires vous voyez ça vaut vraiment
au maire de paris qui a quand même
encore cette latitude mais non la
silhouette dans les mairies
d'arrondissement doors mort à paris le
néanmoins comme maire ce que vous auriez
été favorable à la liberté de conscience
qu avait un temps été évoqué par
françois hollande
finalement changé d'avis et d'ailleurs
le l'amendement a été rejeté par les
députés
un de la liberté de conscience des mères
je crois qu'un certain nombre de maires
se feront représentés par leurs adjoints
ne s'imposera pas de problème bien sûr
il faut appliquer la loi
ensuite chacun est libre de se faire
représenter ce qui se passera a mon avis
oui alors gérard collomb jean luc
mélenchon était à votre place il ya tout
juste une semaine et il accuse le
gouvernement n'ont pas de se tromper de
priorité
oui mais enfin quand même de mener une
politique sociale libérale et ce qu'il
dit vrai je ne sais pas je sais pas
exactement quelle politique voudrait
mené jean luc mélenchon je pense qu'il
ya un certain nombre de réalités qui
aujourd'hui sont devant nous le fait que
la france a perdu de la compétitivité
par rapport aux autres pays
compétitivité coût compétitivité
innovation et le cas voir par exemple
les deux grandes marques nationales de
voiture quelles difficultés que
connaissent aujourd'hui pour
s'apercevoir qu'il faut évoluer
rapidement
sauf à connaître des problèmes plus
douloureux encore donc pas mieux alors
la priorité ce ne sont pas les sujets de
société c'est la compétitivité pour vous
mais c'est ce qui crée l'économie et
donc ceux qui créent la richesse
à partir de là ce qui peut permettre de
redistribuer aux français vous savez moi
je me souviens toujours
c'était lorsque j'étais jeune député en
1986 dans un de mes quartiers
une habitante m'avait dit monsieur
collomb vous êtes là depuis six ans mais
qu'est ce que ça change pour moi dans ma
vie quotidienne
et bien moi ma préoccupation elle est
toujours qu'est ce que ça change dans la
vie quotidienne des gens et donc qu'ils
attendent qu économiquement et
socialement et bien notre pays puisse
aller de l'avant
alors vous êtes en phase avec tous les
discours du moment quand même gérard
collomb parce qu'on l'entend ce mot
compétitivité il revient elle revient
notamment bien sûr en arrière fond de
l'accord qui a été signé entre le
patronat une partie des syndicats dont
la cfdt donc l'accord sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi est ce que vous
dites aujourd'hui aux salariés qui sont
menacées par des plans sociaux qu'ils
doivent faire des efforts pour sauver
leurs emplois
accepté par exemple un gel de leurs
salaires quelques temps accepter de
travailler plus longtemps mais je crois
a dit oui il faut que vous tenez ce
discours de vérité
je tiens le discours il faut que nos
entreprises évoluent je ne parle même
pas des entreprises qui sont en crise
sociale grave dont paul est certaine on
sait pas comment a effectivement on peut
les sauver aujourd'hui faut pas
justement attendre ce type de situation
faut faire évoluer les entreprises donc
pour qu'elle puisse évoluer mais ça veut
dire à quel moment donné qu'elle doit il
respecter les favoris attardés elle
puisse licencier mais que de l'autre
côté on puisse assurer la sécurité
personnelle des salariés
les danois les scandinaves ont fait ça
ont pressé bien
alors qu'on santé et c'est bien à la
fois pour les entreprises et en même
temps pour les salariés pas que rocky de
vie doivent donc consentir des années
nos montebourg et qui était dans votre
ville
une journée ya voilà il le dit
d'ailleurs il faut accepter des efforts
démesurés pour sauver son emploi mais
fait les contrôles et les salariés ils
sont prêts - vous voyez j'ai une
entreprise qui s'appelle veninov sur
venissieux les syndicats la cgt la cfdt
ont accepté un certain nombre d'efforts
bon il espère simplement que la
réciproque sera vrai du côté des
dirigeants d'entreprise la réciproque
c'est de sauver l'emploi et la ville se
remplir le carnet de commandes à
françois hollande avait annoncé durant
sa campagne alors que l'on une loi
contre les licenciements boursiers ou en
tout cas qui ne faut pas justifié
économiquement on en parle plus on s'est
aperçu sans doute que c'était un peu
plus difficile parce que voyez qu a
tourné dans une grande entreprise
à mon avis à dépens de l'entreprise qui
peuvent être extrêmement porteur et donc
qu'il faut développer d'autres par
contre qu'ils deviennent obsolètes
c'est moi mon histoire j'ai commencé à
être élu dans un arrondissement 9e
arrondissement de lyon ce tevez
industriel d industrialisation
fermetures de sites
je sais ce que c'est que d'être
confronté à ce genre de situation et
pour les résoudre
il faut essayer d'innover et de
développer les industries de l'avenir
c'est ce que j'ai fait dans ce quartier
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
aujourd'hui sur l'agglomération
lyonnaise bercy aujourd'hui cherchent
toujours à résoudre le casse-tête de la
taxe à 75% qui me remet d'ailleurs à la
campagne électorale de françois hollande
il avait sorti cette mesure pour essayer
de faire obstacle et jean luc mélenchon
qui montaient est ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui il faut tourner la page et
abandonner cette idée je suis totalement
d'accord avec un livre café philippe
aghion en grand économiste de gauche
s'appelle réformer l'état et il montrait
dans ce livre que la suède à un moment
donné avait taxé beaucoup les
entreprises et que le produit même
des recettes avaient diminué parce
qu'évidemment il y avait un peu
d'évasion entreprenariale qui faisait
que les gens déserté la suède donc à un
certain moment donné il faut
effectivement maîtriser l'impôt de
manière à pouvoir booster le prénom
terme est clair ça veut dire on oublie
c'est pas que ce soit 15%
moi je n'en ai jamais été un très grand
partisan aujourd'hui je les dis mais
aujourd'hui je suis toujours en accord
avec ce que je disais il ya quelques
d'autant plus maintenant que la mesure
était censuré pas possible je n'ai
jamais écrit un livre vous vous en
souvenez il s'appelait et si la france
s'éveillait un certain nombre de choses
que j'analyse est dans ce livre qui à
l'époque semblait un peu hétérodoxes aux
yeux d'un certain nombre de mes amis
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que c'est un
peu la réalité est qu'un certain nombre
de tests aujourd'hui réapparaissent et
on est confronté à la réalité a obligé
de changer
vous avez le faire avant qu'après en
avoir encore plus raison aujourd'hui de
dire qu'il ne faut pas s'encombrer de
cette taxe 75% qui pèche sur l'image
internationale de formule réparé
j'essaie de le formuler à votre place
oui j'ai bien compris et c'est rigolo
nous a été remis aux vainqueurs à la je
me souviens de votre vie que l'on vous
aviez des mots très durs contre certains
écologistes jusqu'au boutiste un ouais
ouais vous aviez affirmé des choses et
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez
j'en ai beaucoup qui veulent
effectivement continuer avec notre
équipe parce que on s'est mariés
économie et écologie et je pense que
c'est la clé de l'avenir et jean vincent
placé
j'estime aujourd'hui que relancer par
exemple l'idée d'explorer et d'exploiter
même les gaz de schiste serait franchir
une ligne rouge est là bien il n'y
aurait plus de ministres écologistes
dans le gouvernement qu'est ce que vous
dites je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'a
demandé jean marc ayrault qui me semble
assez raisonnable c'est qu'en tout cas
on se donne la possibilité d'étudier les
choses et d'aller au bout et les
analyses scientifiques et de nouvelles
énergies fossiles qui veut mais je crois
qu'il va faire parce qu'à un moment
donné si vous voulez on ne peut pas ne
pas avoir d'énergie du tout l'énergie
nucléaire j'ai cru comprendre que
c'étaient pas exactement ce qu'il
fallait faire d'après mes amis
écologistes
le gaz de schiste non plus à prendre
nous dit il faut faire le gaz naturel il
se trouve que l'on n'en a pas et donc
qu'on est obligé de l'importer de russie
ce qui nous met extrêmement dépendant
énergétique énergétiquement est-ce que
c'est cela que l'on veut on dit non non
très bien alors je le disais tout à
l'heure vous tenez à conserver votre
double casquette de sénateurs et de mère
en contradiction donc avec la volonté de
françois hollande en finir avec le cumul
des mandats on va en parler tout de
suite avec suzette bloch de l'agencé
france presse mais d'abord on présente
ce front du refus sénatoriales et
socialistes un sujet signé françois
godin françois rebsamen et gérard
collomb il incarne le noyau dur de la
résistance les deux sénateurs
socialistes mitraille depuis des mois
pour défendre le cumul des mandats et
ils affûtent leurs arguments pour
représenter les collectivités locales
il faut être soi même un élu local
assure-t-on seul problème le maire de
lyon et président de l'agglomération
n'est pas des plus assidus au palais du
luxembourg
il serait même dans la liste des cancres
il avoue lui-même
c'est exact je ne suis pas allé plus
présent parce que je suis maire de lyon
cet absentéisme parlementaire fait
grincer des dents dans le groupe
socialiste et notamment celle du
défenseur de l'as
réforme jean pierre sueur anciens
cumulards repenti quand il a présenté
son dossier de constats d' une fois ou
l'autre il a dû retourner à lyon il lui
est arrivé défendre des amendements
qu'il avait présenté il est impossible
d'être présent à temps plein au sénat et
d'exercer à temps plein la mission qui
est la sienne c'est matériellement
impossible c'est tout françois hollande
a fixé un cap
la loi sera votée avant la fin du
quinquennat mais le flou persiste sur la
date d'application un flou qui fait
grogner les élus aux multiples
casquettes les élections municipales de
2014 approche et faire passer une telle
réforme avant le scrutin serait selon re
se tirer une balle dans le pied
la partie qui jouent contre ces élus
mènent sont partis à l'échec aux
élections suivantes
tout le monde comprend bien que c'est
souvent par le cumul que nous avons
gagné des postes on le gagne et des
majorités parce que la crédibilité des
élus sur le terrain elle s'acquiert au
fur et à mesure des mandats qu'on exerce
à ce jour ils sont 81 sénateurs
socialistes à ne pas respecter le non
cumul adoptée par leur parti et lors du
vote dans l'hémicycle
ils pourront pour une fois compter sur
les voix de la droite
voilà avec donc monsieur collomb s'est
fait bloc de l' agence france-presse qui
est avec nous au sujet de bonsoir
bonsoir gérard collomb bonsoir alors on
a vu une année sujets de société ne sont
pas une priorité pour vous alors pour
vous le cumul des mandats c'est un sujet
de société alors non pour moi je ne
pense pas que ça soit effectivement une
priorité je vais vous expliquer ma
position puisque évidemment un peu un
peu chez ma liste moi je pense que si
vous voulez faire une réforme profonde
de nos institutions
il faudrait reprendre ce qu'est par
exemple en allemagne
la distinction entre le bundestag et le
bundesrat
vous savez le bundesrat et celle là
c'est déjà si on permettait sait
les présidents de région et on ne leur
demande pas de venir et la critique de
mon ami sueur était d'une certaine
manière à la fois justifié mais en même
temps très peu pertinente
on ne leur demande pas de venir sur tous
les projets de loi mais par contre tous
les projets de lois qui touchent aux
collectivités locales en allemagne
alors pour le coup non seulement il
discute mais il doit y est même y avoir
une majorité au bundesrat pour que les
lois soient adoptées
vous comprenez bien qu'on va aboutir un
déséquilibre des pouvoirs
extraordinaires c'est que les nerfs
demain les présidents de région les
présidents de conseils généraux
et bien ne pèseront plus dans la france
nous sommes déjà dans un état
hypercentralisé demain ce sera encore
pire
mais alors françois hollande s'est
trompé c'est un engagement de campagne
nous avait fait sa campagne
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
vous opposer frontalement lui coûter
pour moi ce n'est pas une affaire voyez
je suis je suis quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui se satisfait avec la ville
de lyon je vais rester quand même
quelques temps ici et vous verrez très
souvent présent sur la loi de
décentralisation
parce que ça c'est un vrai sujet pour
moi et ça va ou soeurs avant la loi de
décentralisation il y aura la loi sur
non cumul ou moi je sais que le sucre le
27 mars et ont concédé m j'ai pas mon me
dit par exemple qu'un certain nombre de
députés 45 qui sont à la fois député et
maire demain si on leur demande de
choisir ils feront ce que la plupart des
maires font et choisiront de rester
maire et à ce moment là on me dit que
leurs suppléants ne pourrait pas monter
donc on sera obligé de faire 40 cette
élection partielle
est-ce qu'on va vers
ce genre de situation je n'en suis pas
sûr
le gouvernement étudie la question et il
pense pense pour un calendrier en 2016
ou 2017
est-ce que vous voteriez ci s'est
appliqué en 2017 chez en veut adopter
pour 2017
pourquoi pas 2020 mais franchement moi
je n'en faire part dans le canal
je n'en fais pas un problème personnel
et demain je choisirais sans problème la
ville de lyon mais je pense sur le fond
que vous voyez si vous n'avez pas des
présidents d'exécutifs ou sénat à quoi
sert le sénat
si vous n'avez pas les dirigeants de
régions les dirigeants et les conseils
généraux les dirigeants et
d'agglomération et que vous avez ceux
qui ne sont pas dans les exécutifs
évidemment que ça va être moins
représentatifs de ce qu'est aujourd'hui
l'âge
gérard collomb vous aborder une question
très important là où dit sinon la
présence des ex de représentants de
l'exécutif régional notamment
départemental local au sénat alors là ça
nous pose la question évidemment de la
séparation des pouvoirs sur m6 que 10
heures il dit je que vous faites des
amendements pour lyon que vous faites
des déchets les assez brouillon la
france
soyez sûr la loi de décentralisation
je suis sans doute un de ceux qui est
porté une certaine vision de la france
ça fait deux ou trois mois que je
travaille avec les ministères
ils savent que j'ai des idées assez
précis sur la façon dont il faudrait
organiser non pas simplement
l'agglomération lyonnaise nous le
faisons par ailleurs mais en même temps
comment qu'il ya un conflit pour
l'éprouver laser ou fille d'intérêts
entre celui des neuf ans son exécutif
mais moi je défends toi mon exécuté
riche je peux voler à moi j'ai une vie
législatif j'ai une vision une certaine
vision de la france dans l'aménagement
du territoire aujourd'hui on est dans
une situation un peu difficile du point
de vue de la dépense publique
si on veut faire des vraies économies
d'échelle il faut aller vers une
décentralisation en profondeur faire en
sorte voyez la france elle est très
diverse faire en sorte que sur les
régions rurales
on met en avant le département faire en
sorte ensuite que l'on conforte les 100
premières villes qui lie la france
allait faire ses voeux on leur parlait
tout à l'heure c'est ce que vous avez
mis en oeuvre bah c'est ce qu'on essaye
de faire
mais cette vision de la france par
exemple je trouve que les grands
problèmes de l'île de france à la fois
de développement économique et en même
temps un problème social ces lavoirs 114
intercommunalités donc de ne pas être
capable de mettre des politique
d'ensemble en oeuvre voyez la différence
par exemple entre l'agglomération
lyonnaise dans les problèmes des
banlieues et les banlieues de l'île de
france parce que nous on a une capacité
de gérer de manière globale su quand
vous avez l'échiné montfermeil dans une
intercommunalité
comment voulez-vous faire marcher les
jours puisque comment comment se passe
votre semaine parce que vous êtes maire
de lyon merde président de
l'agglomération sénateurs de comment ça
se passe quand je suis à paris le mardi
et le mercredi et puis à lormont
agglomération comment ça se passe en
général l'indicé soit conseil municipal
soit conseil d'agglomération donc les
deux de vos mandats le lundi 2 mardi
il m'a donné suite jeudi vendredi samedi
et dimanche
je suis chez moi oui et est ce que vous
pensez pas que justement dans le cadre
d'une décentralisation accrue d'avoir de
se consacrer à plein temps à sa mairie
pourrait être quand même plus pertinents
mais écoutez on a parlé des problèmes
économiques et sociaux
vous avez entendu que on a des points de
vue peut-être un peu originaux je pense
qu' un certain nombre d'élus locaux ont
les points de vue que je viens de
développer c'est à dire parce qu'ils
connaissent déjà
et économique et social il porte une
certaine idée du développement
aujourd'hui moi maire de lyon j'ai déjà
un peu de peine à me faire écouter le
maire d'une ville de 30 mille habitants
si demain il est plus sénateur où il
était député
alors là je vais vous dire qu'on ne va
plus l'écouté du tout pour les intérêts
de votre agglomération papoul est normal
parce qu'ils voient comment les choses
se développent
comment vivent les entreprises dans sa
ville qu'il connaît un peu la réalité
économique économique et sociale et donc
ces cercles littéraires qui n'ont pas
demandé non pas cette vision c'est que
joua dans les dents les parties d'une
certaine manière c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont dans les appareils et
que quelquefois essayé de tempérer ceux
qui sont dans les appareils politiques
par on va dire la connaissance du réel
qu'on ceux qui sont sur le terrain c'est
pas mal croyons tous que vous nous
annoncez que le sénat votera pas le nom
que moi je vous annonce rien parizeau
l'es4 mais ce n'est pas un problème
cg c'est d'attirer l'attention sur
effectivement l'équilibré des pouvoirs
dans notre pays si il n'y a que ça qui
peut faire avancer l'avenir de la france
alors on se sacrifiera pour l'avenir de
la française je n'en fais pas du tout un
problème personnel
vous n'allez pas sacrifier votre
implantation locale et ça c'est clair
le fait que vous soyez au service d'une
ville que qu'à votre passion oui oui
c'est d'ailleurs pour défendre ma ville
que je suis là d'ailleurs c'est ce que
me reprocher monsieur sûr de défendre
trop ma ville lui défend peut-être un
peu orléans il regrette même peut-être
de ne plus en être mère donc évidemment
que chacun défend une position à partir
de la vie qu'il a des réalités qu'il
observe
il n'y a pas de théorie comme ça des
idées qui serait totalement abstrait
c'est bien à partir du
réalité magdi françois rebsamen à propos
des opposants au cumul ou mais je n'aime
pas ce mot
c'est pas comme cela que je vais traiter
les problèmes voyez je regardais ça veut
dire que vous seriez prêt finalement
voté le projet de loi si jamais il fini
si on me dit que c'est essentiel pour
l'avenir de la france
mais comme comme le disent dans un vrai
débat moi je veux bien que vous méritiez
avec jean pierre sueur dans une émission
puis qu'on débatte sur ce sujet
comment il faut organiser la france les
territoires la représentation des
territoires par rapport au pouvoir
jacobin vous rendez compte le pouvoir
jacobin en france cela fait des siècles
et des siècles et donc la
décentralisation peine à la faire et au
moment où on l'a fait on va dire allez
rentrer dans les provinces et on
n'entend plus parler de vous mais vous
l'avez eu ce débat avec françois
hollande et françois hollande à trancher
ce débat il est déjà quand même chez pas
tranché non contre auch
on nous reproche quelquefois ne pas être
dans le débat qui est aujourd'hui par la
fonction présidentielle
une toute puissance de l'exécutif
c'est effectivement parce qu'on a
tranché à un moment donné sur un point
on ne peut plus parler de ce point alors
dans ce cas là c'est une cour qu'il
pourrait aller et ce n'est pas un
parlement parce que vous avez eu
l'occasion de rappeler à françois
hollande ce qu'il devait au cumul qu'il
a exercé pendant quelques temps de
député et maire depuis le franchement je
n'ai jamais parlé avec françois hollande
et avec le premier ministre
ddd problème de cumul des mandats
j'aurais parlé effectivement des
problèmes économiques des problèmes de
désindustrialisation des problèmes de la
décentralisation
parce que je trouve ça fondamentale je
vous réponds parce qu'évidemment vous
avez mis ceci au coeur de l'émission
mais pour moi c'est pas une priorité du
tout quand vous avez fait votre choix il
est clair et net alors il ya beaucoup de
questions sur dailymotion qui porte sur
les indemnités d'élu je veux combien
gagnez-vous par mois toutes indemnités
confondues expliquer un peu ou aux
téléspectateurs il ya beaucoup de gens
qui croient que lorsque l'on est comme
moi sénateur maire président du grand
lyon on cumule les indemnités non elles
sont plafonnées
ça fait combien au total c'est 9800
euros non kate elle toutes les
animations frais à peu près dix neuf
mille euros les trois les 3 mai
donc moi je ne touche que 9000 parce que
effectivement je travaille gratuitement
pour la ville de lyon pour le grand lyon
et donc c'est parce que c'est comment
dirais-je ma passion ma vie elle est à
lyon dans l'organisation le
développement de ces grandes métropoles
mais ce n'est pas le reste que oui parce
expliqué aujourd'hui donc les élus sont
écrêté et donc qu'ils redistribuent un
certain nombre de conseillers municipaux
ou d'adjoint le reste de leurs
indemnités
donc moi je répare
le répartir aux collectivités comment
certains propose de répartir ses volumes
pas pourquoi mais vous voulez si vous
voulez si on va aller en profondeur il
faut pouvoir regarder à nouveau toute la
législation voiliers et les indemnités
des élus
moi par exemple mon adjoint à
l'urbanisme adjoint à l'urbanisme a lyon
c'est quand même quelque chose une
fonction à plein temps il doit je crois
est à peu près à 3000 euros d'indemnités
ça veut dire que s'il n'a pas un cumul
des mandats se trouve dans une situation
extrêmement difficile id donc ça veut
dire que il faut qu'on ait de pas lui
spécialement mais d'autres effectivement
on les aide ceux qui justement n'ont pas
d'autres fonctions l'ami vous compreniez
bien que ça fait un peu bizarre qu'on
naît de ces élus bon ils vont être
d'autant plus favorable à vous tout en
plus je sais s'il espère franchement que
toutes celles et tous ceux qui viennent
se faire élire sur mes listes sont un
peu favorable à moi parce que s'il y
avait des gens qui y sont défavorables
évidemment ça devient problématique
alors qu'hier question alors donc jean
claude gaudin dit que finalement vous
vous voterez le texte que l'on fait sous
sarkozy notamment quand ils ont voté le
conseiller territorial auquel il était
très opposé
finalement vous voterez le texte c'est
ce qui va se passer alors j'en sais rien
on verra à chacun prendra le moment venu
ses responsabilités moi je vous dis je
ne suis même pas sûr que le texte arrive
et je ne sais pas dans quelles
conditions il arrivera donc quand on me
le présentera je dirais comme je le dis
aujourd'hui franchement ce que j'en
pense très bien on a déjà compris à ce
que vous en pensez
parce que vous l'affirmé haut et fort
merci beaucoup zézette d'avoir été avec
toute cette semaine dernière partie de
preuves par 3 avec perrine tarneaud qui
va nous rejoindre de public sénat on va
ouvrir quelques dossiers lyonnais avec
vous ma
à commencer par l'affront fait à votre
vive et oui comme lyon n'a pas été
retenu comme site et de la gastronomie
sophie normand l'image de lyon on prend
un sacré coup
la ville des bouchons ses bistrots
mondialement connu a été rejetée du
réseau décidé de la gastronomie au
profit de trois autres villes paris un
geste ou rédigeons rien d'étonnant pour
marc de champérard critique
gastronomique et lyonnais d'origine
lyon n'est tout simplement plus à la
hauteur aujourd'hui et je suis
malheureux de dire ça mais lyon des plus
lents lyon lyon n'est plus une ville qui
donne faim avant c'était les grenouilles
dans la dombes la plus drôle dans la
dombes
avant c'était le vent debout jollet
aujourd'hui moi je préfère boire un
gamin de toine que de trop nombreux
beaujolais il y avait aussi les fameuses
écrevisses pattes rouges qui aujourd'hui
avec la pollution n'existe plus
c'est pourtant à lyon que tous les deux
ans se tient le salon international de
la restauration qui pendant cinq jours
rassemble plus de 160 mille visiteurs et
pas moins de douze mille deux cents
chefs de cuisine
venus des quatre coins de la planète
lyon reste aussi la deuxième ville
française la plus étoilée après paris
pas suffisant le bien manger et le bien
boire ne se mesure pas toujours en
nombre de chefs étoilés
c'est la pratique sociale dure parce la
convialité et donc les critères qui ont
amené la commission à se décider pour la
mise en place d'un réseau avec ces trois
villes paris
rungis dijon et tours relève plus de la
complémentarité des dossiers et de la
rigueur des dossiers qui ont été
présentées lors solidité de quoi énerver
très fort gérard collomb qui aurait
confié son entourage
je ne veux plus voir à lyon 1 seul
de ministres de ce gouvernement
de merde moi je ne parle pas comme cela
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure je mets de
la passion mais toujours de manière
courtoise nevo légendaires coups de
gueule quand même
non mais
sur la cité de la gastronomie alors si
vous voulez c'est clair que la décision
me semble totalement injustifiable
d'ailleurs je suis persuadé qu'on y
reviendra
voyez on a eu le bocuse d'or
effectivement pendant trois jours
c'était un événement où il y avait 180
8000 personnes qui étaient présentes
17500 chef un repas avec 500 étoiles
on a aussi ce n'est pas là qu'est la
gastronomie alors je ne sais pas où elle
se trouve
la prochaine fois je vous invite mais
quand même qu'on vient d'entendre dans
ce dans ce reportage ce critique
gastronomique qui dit que lyon n'est
plus puisque c'est elle c'est plus
tellement la ville du terroir français
de la bonne cuisine vieux il a
totalement tort vous savez c'est une
phrase de paul bocuse qui disait la
cuisine la gastronomie c'est le produit
est pourquoi à lyon est une région assez
exceptionnel parce qu'elle est entourée
effectivement par la dombes par donc
vous avez un peu de poisson par la
bresse où vous avez évidemment les
poulets les chapons par la haute savoie
et la savoie par la drôme tous les
produits du terroir qui sont autour de
l'agglomération lyonnaise non c'est une
ville de grande gastronomie et venez-y
quand vous ne se trompe aussi ça nous
fera plaisir vous pensez qu'on va
revenir en arrière sur les trois villes
qui ont été choisis parmi 28 saisons
alors qu'elles devraient exigeant le
président du jury ont fait une cité de
la gastronomie ou dans l'hôtel dieu
qu'est une architecture de soufflot en
réserve à cette cité de la gastronomie
avec quinze mille mètres carrés et donc
il nous dit la cité de la gastronomie
mérite mieux qu'une chambre de bonne
vous comprenez bien que quinze mille
mètres carrés dans un hôtel dans un
hôpital du xviiie siècle rénovée par les
plus grands architectes français ça fait
quand même pas totalement plaisir alors
on vous est sur la même ligne que france
avec soi-même sur sur le cumul des
mandats meurent là il a ses boîtes
bahdja sert votre ennemi
moi je n'ai jamais demandé à ce que lyon
soit unique à des prêts à partager que
tout le monde vous savez qu'on aime ou
qu'on n'est pas le titre cité de la
gastronomie toute façon la fera quand
même et on continuera à tirer à lyon des
centaines de milliers de personnes
le tourisme l'an dernier à lyon a
augmenté de 15% dans une année de crise
donc on va continuer à essayer d'aller
de l'avant
non on quitte la gastronomie à le
gouvernement vient d'autoriser
l'expérimentation d'une salle de shoot à
paris est ce que vous êtes vous
favorable à ce genre d'expérimentation
est ce que vous seriez prêt à le tenter
aussi à lyon on a nos propres procédé où
on est c'est effectivement de traiter
les problèmes de toxicomanie
il se trouve que son premier acte de
consommation mais je connais trop bien
adjoint est professeur de médecine
spécialiste du sida donc qu'on essaye de
traiter à notre manière et donc chacun
traite comme il souhaite c'est
problématique mais j'ai pas compris ce
que vous êtes favorable ou non à cette
expérience ce n'est pas comme cela que
l'acoss avait choisi une autre voie a
absolument bon bonnes questions sur
dailymotion autour de la semaine de
quatre jours et demi à l'école
est ce que vous allez l'appliquer ou non
à lyon bat la montre et septembre
le problème et il est d'une simplicité
j'allais dire biblique et je les dis
d'ailleurs à jean marc ayrault simpson
soupe mais ça coûte 5 millions sur lyon
et donc au même moment où le
gouvernement diminue les dotations des
collectivités locales peut pas leur
demander en même temps de dépenser plus
donc cela veut dire que soi et ça se
posera pour tous les maires de france
les caisses d'allocations familiales
vont suivre et donc permettre de payer
une partie de ces frais là soient
effectivement je ne vois pas comment
nous pourrons le faire voyez moi pour la
première fois j'ai eu un budget cette
année extrêmement difficile à faire avec
ce qu'on appelle un effet de ciseaux
c'est à dire que mes dépenses augmenter
un tout petit peu plus vite que mes
recettes
si demain je mets 5 millions de plus en
dépenses alors là je m
retrouvez dans une situation extrêmement
difficile alors menacé le gouvernement
de ne de ne pas prendre en charge ces 5
millions et donc les lui dire on
l'appliquera pas au moins en septembre
2013 septembre 2014 paix date mais vous
lui demander de trouver une solution
j'attends une réponse je les dis à jean
marc ayrault je les ai vues il ya trois
jours jean marc ayrault et je le dis moi
j'attends que la caisse nationale
d'allocations familiales indique aux
caisses locales de combien d'argent
elles disposeront pour mettre en oeuvre
la réforme sur cette réforme vincent
peillon et s'est isolé il a péché par
manque de concertation j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas il est clair que ça a
un coût donc si on décide d'une réforme
il faut y mettre les moyens voyez quand
à lyon qu'il faut je crois rang avec les
antes à lyon je prends une décision je
m'arrange pour que ma décision elle soit
un peu financés autrement ce ne sont que
des intentions playoffs on lui pardonne
un fonds incitatives l'univers de 250
millions d'euros le fond il est pour la
première année et il est donc d'un
million 700 mille mais moi je vais
donner sur les quatre années
voyez au bout de la première année c'est
5 millions la deuxième on passe à 7
la deuxième à 8 et la troisième à neuf
donc c'est sur ce genre de problématique
qui vous ne comprenez bien c'est pas
pour chagriné le monde que je prends ce
type de position et que je fais ces
interrogations pour embêter le
gouvernement aussi parce qu'à lui tout
ça ne regarde jamais les bons élèves
ils vont l'appliquer des mois de
septembre ils ont dit on a les moyens et
non merci
paris a les moyens moi j'en suis heureux
pour paris je me réjouis toujours que
mes amis soit dans la facilité mais je
sais par exemple que j'ai signé avec
bertrand delanoë
il ya quelque temps un texte qui disait
attention la péréquation que vous nous
demandez où vous taxer les grandes
villes ça commence aujourd'hui à être
au-dessus de nos moyens
donc je pense que les problématiques que
je développe sont aussi partagées par
bertrand delanoë
vous seriez vous prêt à débaptiser les
écoles maternelles pour un terme un
petit peu plus neutre il ya une députée
socialiste sandrine mazetier qui
voudraient débaptiser parce qu'elle
trouve que jour genre et c'est sexiste
école maternelle si on veut les
l'école maternelle je n'y vois aucun et
transitant genre est aussi père m'a
alors séparé bon bah vous me direz quel
est le mot nicolas rion fait en tout cas
la théorie du genre vous trouver du
contenu
école élémentaire écoles la première
vente tout cela c'est loin des
préoccupations fondamentales des
français alors on va parler un petit peu
organisation collectivités territoriales
puisque avec monsieur merci vous avez
décidé et un peu imposer une scission en
deux du département du rhône en
renforçant l'agglomération lyon qui sera
ainsi la première grandes métropoles
françaises
est ce que maintenant finalement
l'organisation des territoires et
rentrer les mains des élus qui en font
un peu ce qu'ils veulent dans le sens où
il organise les territoires qu'ils
connaissent bien
non je ne le dirai pas exactement comme
ça on a beaucoup discuté avec marylise
lebranchu et donc elle souhaiterait
pouvoir créer un certain nombre d'autres
métropoles comme ce que nous allons
faire à lyon mais il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
villes évident qu'elle un certain nombre
de villes sont plus réticentes que nous
par exemple sur marseille elle aimerait
bien qu'une initiative qui soit comme
celle de lyon
salut arrangerait des choses quand elle
va à marseille ce serait plus facile
côté jeu nancy qui pensent mais il y
pense il faut qu'ils fassent mieux
qu'ils pensaient il faut effectivement
qu'ils agissent pour la faire mais en
tout cas vous vous avez extrême était
extrêmement rapide on vous reproche même
un manque de concertation vous l'avais
un peu imposée avec michel mercier à
tout le monde dans le département vous
savez il ya toujours sur tous les sujets
de bonnes raisons de ne pas avancer et
donc sur ce sujet en particulier qui est
remonte
effectivement c'est un choc création du
département à la révolution française
bon tu avais connu quelques peu de
stationner là 6793 mais c'est vrai que
c'est une révolution
vous voyez dans un moment où on dit il
faut faire des économies de structure on
peut pas essayer de d'économiser de
l'argent public
simplement par de petits ajustements il
faut de grandes réformes et là tout d'un
coup où il y avait sur un territoire
deux entités la communauté urbaine et le
département il y en aura plus qu'une
évidemment ça fait avancer les choses et
en plus c'est extrêmement
complémentaires voyez le département il
fait par exemple tout ce qui est social
nous nous faisons tout ce qui est urbain
dans nos logements
on logeait des gens dans nos logements
sociaux mais c'était le conseil général
qu'il parle le rsa s'occupait des
problèmes sociaux et de l'insertion des
gens le fait qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
unité sur ces deux politiques évidemment
que ça va faire avancer les choses
pour finir cette interview gérard
collomb je voulais vous poser une
question concernant la présidence du
sénat on a pu entendre ces dernières
semaines des critiques un peu feutré
contre le président jean pierre bel
accusé par certains dans votre majorité
1 notamment de ne pas être assez présent
de ne pas assez s'occuper des relations
avec les autres groupes de la majorité
est ce que je voulais c'est que ceux qui
me critiquent est non est-ce que vous
aussi vous le trouvez trop timide jean
pierre bel
non écoutez je crois que il ya un
véritable problème c'est que non mais
papa de jean pierre bel le problème
simplement c'est que les lois ne passe
plus au sénat est donc évidemment c'est
une problématique un peu un peu
difficile qui devrait s'occuper un peu
plus de s'est prononcée c'est pas lui
c'est que il faut que les groupes qui
composent au moins une majorité
sénatoriale se met de temps en temps
d'accord pour faire passer certains
textes
c'est mieux quand même vous avez
l'impression que ce sont les ambitieux
qui se réveille en vue des élections
sénatoriales de 2014
non je crois pas simplement il semble
qu'aujourd'hui une distorsion dans une
majorité c'est vrai au sénat comme c'est
vrai dans une majorité municipale
il vaut mieux quand même que les gens
qui sont dans
majorité ils votent et même texte parce
qu'autrement dans ce cas là c'est un
divorce par consentement mutuel
à propos de distorsion de majorité et
vous vous avez connu certains moments
difficiles on va dire avec les verts
avec les écologistes pensent aux
dernières législatives vous étiez érigé
contre le candidat vert et comment vont
se passer les alliances en vue des
municipales en 2014
moi j'essaye de faire une grande liste
de rassemblement dans lesquelles les
écologistes on va dire qu'ils ont là une
vision responsable du développement
urbain seront partie prenante et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas trop mal
parti
vous la redite ce qui m'aime me suive
non ceux qui ont une vision semblable de
la ville parce que l on développe
beaucoup d'écologie à lyon peut être une
des villes dans lesquelles se pense la
ville du futur maire invité mois dans
une autre émission je vous parlerai de
la ville intelligente de demain c'est
pas d'écologie mais on va dire un mot
sur deux animaux
pour conclure la baby et népal alors
jamais on n'a autant parlé de lyon que
de fait j'ai vu ce pont pour les
éléphants de ses éléphants effectivement
deux grands sujets côté moi je demande à
ce que un jour il y ait quelqu'un de
sérieux la plus haute autorité des
terrines air qui viennent trancher la
question
lorsque parce que en attendant il parce
que si vous voulez aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas si c'est des spécialistes de la
question éléphantesque c'est la première
fois sans doute qu'ils étaient saisis
sur des efforts mais bon ils vont
trancher mais en attendant quand même
ses éléphants ils sont là et c'est un
risque pour la population
non c'est pas de baby et népal si vous
passez par lyon allait plutôt courir les
bouchons à merlimont gérard collomb
d'avoir été avec nous bonsoir à tous la
semaine prochaine c'est michel sapin le
ministre du travail qui sera notre
invité bonsoir
se renseigner sur les programmes
voir ou revoir les émissions suivre le
fil d'information politique et
parlementaire pour vivre la politique en
temps réel connectez vous et réagissez
sur publicsenat.fr
bonjour à tous un lieu une histoire le
22 janvier 1963 été signé à paris ce
qu'on appelle le traité de l'élysée qui
signait et qui scellait la
réconciliation franco-allemande à cette
occasion et pour parler d'europe
nous sommes venus ici même à
scy-chazelles un petit village perché
sur les collines au dessus de la ville
de metz
dans ce village typique des douceurs de
la vallée de la moselle a vécu robert
schuman l'un des pères de l'europe je
vous propose d'aller à la découverte de
sa maison là où il a vécu une grande
partie de sa vie et surtout de découvrir
cet homme historique
robert schuman est mort en 1963 c'est à
dire l'année même où fut signé ce traité
de l'élysée avec la signature du général
de gaulle et du chancelier allemand
adenauer un traité à l'origine de ce
qu'on appelle encore aujourd'hui tout à
fait communément ce fameux couple
franco-allemand un traité qui est le
fait de deux très forte personnalité de
gaulle et adenauer comme nous le
rappelle marie lebon ce jour le 22
janvier 1963 il y à de gaulle l'homme du
18 juin à ses côtés konrad adenauer
lentilles nazis le chancelier de la
nouvelle allemagne dans les salons de
l'elysée
il signe la réconciliation de leurs deux
pays les deux hommes ont appris à se
connaître septembre 1958 première
rencontre au domicile du français à
colombey les deux églises
puis le 8 juillet 1962 il assiste
ensemble à une messe dans la cathédrale
des rois à reims où 5000 personnes les
acclame
enfin en septembre 1962 charles de
gaulle est reçu par son homologue
allemand et devient le premier chef
d'état français à se rendre en rhénanie
depuis napoléon
quelques mois plus tard le traité fixe
les objectifs d'une coopération
bilatérale a cru organisation de sommets
militaire ou intergouvernementaux pour
soutenir les échanges dans différents
domaines
la défense les relations internationales
ou encore le commerce plus important
sans doute le traité rapproche les
peuples la jeunesse en particulier
l'apprentissage des langues
l'harmonisation des diplômes et le
jumelage sont autant de pierres qui
aujourd'hui encore sont la base de
l'amitié franco allemande
cette réconciliation n'est pourtant pas
seulement le fait de ces deux géants de
l'histoire en 1950 c'est à dire cinq ans
seulement on s'en rend pas compte mais
cinq ans seulement après la dernière
guerre robert schuman propose une idée
extrêmement audacieuse celle de mettre
sous une gestion commune la production
de l'allemagne et de la france du
charbon et de l'acier
c'est cette idée qui est aujourd'hui
toujours à la base de la construction
européenne telle que nous la connaissons
objet essentiel que servir la paix
l'europe n'a pas été fait
nous avons eu la guerre l'euro atteint
d'un coup ni dans une construction
d'ensemble elle changera par des
réalisations concrètes créant d'abord
sur l'égalité des faits eh bien la voilà
derrière moi la maison de robert schuman
une maison de vignerons une maison dont
nous découvrirons intimité dans quelques
instants une maison dotée depuis peu
d'une annexe d'une extension beaucoup du
moderne beaucoup de plus contemporaine
on peut y méditer sur l'europe bien sûr
on peut également y travailler
j
bonjour max bonjour monsieur vous êtes
allemand vous venez de dresde et vous
faites votre service civique ici même
dans la maison de robert schuman
nous sommes dans le bureau de robert
schuman là où il travaillait là où il
réfléchissait à l'europe est ce qu'on
peut dire que c'est véritablement à ce
bureau son bureau qu'est née l'idée de
la construction européenne telle qu'on
la connaît aujourd'hui tout à fait son
bureau joue une rôle essentiel dans la
concession européenne on ne peut dire ça
parce que c'était ici qu'il a rédigé sa
fameuse déclaration du 9 mai 1950 alors
il faut rappeler que robert-schuman ici
dans cette maison vivait seule il y
avait à dire que sa gouvernante qui
l'assistait ce qui lui laissait pas mal
de loisirs parmi ceux ci la bibliophilie
c'était un passionné un amoureux des
livres la preuve ces bibliothèques
derrière nous c'est tout à fait correct
au personnel aimait beaucoup les livres
à la fin de sa vie il avait plus que 8
mai livres en fête
alors il était en vrai bibliophiles et
ici on va la partie politique de sa
collection donc qui traite des relations
entre la france et l'allemagne de
l'histoire de l'allemagne de l'histoire
de la france de l'histoire de l'europe
en fait il était un homme multi langues
aussi il parlait français allemands
anglais italiens luxembourgeois grecque
et là tu en voilà
et dans tous ces langues on trouve des
livres dans sa collection alors c'était
un homme exceptionnel
autre passion de robert schuman on le
sait moins c'est la musique
la preuve ce piano qui est son piano où
il joue et très régulièrement
c'était pour lui une véritable passion
cette musique s'est emplie un os dans
son bureau alors c'est pas normal au but
c'est pas typique pour un bureau mais
pour robert chemin tu étais très très
important c'était sa mère qui a appris
que jouer le piano